Sarah and Paul live with their two sons
they are one of millions of families who
in the next two years will see the
biggest fall in their household
disposable income on record really
really worried about the future
um
things are getting more and more
expensive you go to the shop we go to
for a a normal everyday shop which used
to be about maybe 20 30 pounds for a
family of two kids and two adults is now
turned into 70 pounds we are
just living
just on the breadline you know we we
shop so carefully
a few miles down the road in Sheffield
the council here is facing surging costs
but like other local authorities the
chancellor has lent on them to raise
council tax by up to five percent to
help balance budgets but it might not be
enough
communities like these have already
borne the brunt of years of public
sector cuts and councils have seen a
reduction in the amount of Grants they
get from central government by nearly 40
percent since 2010. and this budget
looks set to make things even tighter
Louise Askew helps run this community
center that provides help and support to
the local area she's worried that a rise
in council tax will squeeze already
struggling families this community is a
great is a working Community a lot of
these people work and you you earn what
you earn where do you find that extra
money from to pay for these Services
where do you find that money it's just
it's just not there so that means that
people then live in poverty
there's an art class going on down the
corridor while the chancellor has found
more money for benefits and pensions
some here are still worried people are
struggling to buy food now so where
they're going to get the extra money
from to pay the council tax and these
people not going to pay the council tax
an ending card putting more and more
debt on on them so it's a vicious circle
there's people out here who can't afford
it and uh
that's not fair for them Mike Chaplin is
a labor counselor while he welcomes some
of the support put in place by the
budget he says people will struggle to
get through this winter
what is your gut feeling about what this
budget means for the people who you
represent
it means more hard times more
difficulties in in making ends meet I
think it's
it's also worsening people's life
chances
um the Health's going to deteriorate
um
with those hard choices for more than a
decade many communities have suffered
from public sector Cuts add to that
Rising inflation and the cost of living
crisis and for millions of people the
storm is far from over Nick Martin Sky
News Sheffield